前回のパートでは皆さんのAIエージェントに図のいわゆるチャットモデルというのを追加したかと思います。
ようやく会話ができるようになったかと思うんですけども、しかしですね、まだこのAIエージェントにはまだまだ欠点があります。
実際その欠点というのを皆様にも体験していただけたらと思うので、こちらのチャットの方にですね、
私の名前は田中です。 このように一回送りたいと思います。
田中さんこんにちはと返してくれました。 最後ですね、質問をしてみたいと思います。
私の名前は何ですか?先ほど田中と名乗りましたから。 どうでしょう?
ごめんなさい、名前についての情報を持っていません。 先ほど伝えたばっかなんですが、覚えてないようです。
これは何かと言いますと、まだこのAIエージェントには記憶という機能がないので、 直前の会話すら覚えていない状況になるんですね。
皆様もChatGPTを使ったことあるかなと思うんですが、基本的には過去の会話の記録、 これも学習した上で回答を出してくれたり、
記憶、覚えてくれるような機能というのが備わっているのは、皆さんもね、実際チャットGPTを使ってみて体感としてあるかと思うんですけども、まだこのAIエージェントには記憶という機能がございませんので、実際に記憶する機能というのを追加をしていきたいと思います。
そこで記憶する機能というのが、このAIエージェントノードの真ん中にぶら下がっているメモリと言われるこちらになるんですね。
ですので、まずはこちらの下、プラスボタンを押していただいてメモリというのを追加していきます。
メモリというのは任意のものでいろいろ指定はできるんですけども、今回シンプルメモリというメモリを追加していこうかなと思うので、こちらを選択します。
そうしますとこういった画面が出てきますが、重要な設定内容としてはこちらですね、コンテキストウィンドウと書いてあるところ、こちらデフォルトでは5というふうに書いてありますが、こちらですね、重要な部分となっておりまして、これは過去何回分の会話を記憶しますかという設定になっています。
今は5という数字が入っているので、5回分の会話の記録を記憶すると。そういった設定になっているので、こちら2で例えば10にしたりだとか、それこそ3に減らしたりだとかね、それでも2で設定することができるので、実際に作成するワークフローの目的に応じて、この記憶の機能をつけるのか、そもそもつけないのか、
つけるとしたらどれくらいパイワーを記憶させたいのか、こういったところから設定する必要があるということで、こちら押さえておいていただけたらと思います。
また、今回はデフォルトの5のまま進めていこうかなと思いますので、特に変更はせず、このままキャンバス画面に戻って、ちゃんと記憶をしてくれるのかどうかというのを確認してみたいと思いますので、
最後ですね、私の名前は田中です。これを送信します。
そうしますと、田中さんこんにちは、先ほどと似たような回答が返ってきましたが、
違う点としましては、このメモリのところにきちんとチェックがついて、実行されましたよっていうのを確認できたかと思います。
ここで再度は覚えてくれなかった名前をもう一回聞いてみましょう。私の名前は何ですか?
はい、あなたの名前は田中さんです。よろしくお願いします。ようやく覚えてくれました。はい、これでAI自身の記憶をするメモリー機能というのが追加できた状態となります。
しかしですね、AIエージェントの制御においてメモリー機能よりももっと強力でさらに重要な機能というのがあります。それがシステムメッセージと言われる機能になります。
このシステムメッセージとはですね、AIに与える行動指針であったり、役割設定のことなんですね。
こちら、AIエージェントノードを開いていただいて、下、アドオプション、こちらを選択すると、一番上にシステムメッセージというのが表示されるかと思います。
こちらを押すと、実際にシステムメッセージを追加することができるんですが、先ほどもお伝えした通り、行動指針、役割設定ということなので、AIエージェントがユーザーと会話する際に、どういった役割で回答したらいいのか、どういった立場で回答したらいいのか、そういったマニュアルみたいなものをここで設定することができます。
実際にこちらをわかりやすく設定をしていきたいと思いますので、システムメッセージの欄にですね、例えば、関西弁で回答してください。
このようにシステムメッセージで指示を与えてみたいと思います。
設定が完了しましたら、再度セーブをして、ちゃんと関西人になりきってくれるか、関西弁で回答してくれるかどうか試してみたいと思います。
このように質問するとですね、しっかり関西弁で大きいな、あいの状態めっちゃええでと、非常にコテコテな関西弁を返してくれたと思います。
今までの回答と非常にですね、口調っていうのがより変わったかと思うんですね。確認いただけたかと思います。
このようにシステムメッセージを使用すると、応答のスタイルだけでなく、指示の処理方法までAIのコントロール、制御というのができるようになりますので、非常に重要な機能としてシステムメッセージ、ぜひ覚えていただけたらと思います。
このシステムメッセージはですね、AIエージェント、オートメーションでなくAIエージェントの開発において、最も重要といっても過言ではない機能になります。
理由としましては、今後様々なツールというのをですね、AIエージェントに追加をしていくにあたって、このシステムメッセージがその与えられたツールの使い方
っていうのを制御するために必要不可欠になってきますので、こちらを絶対に覚えていただけたらと思います。
また補足としましては、今回は関西弁でっていうように日本語で指示をしましたが、AIというのはですね、英語の指示の方が非常に精度が高く
回答を出してくれます。なぜかというと、そもそもLLM、チャットGPTとかはLLMというモデルになるんですけども、
やはりですね、日本語の情報よりかも英語の情報の方が情報量としては世の中に多いんですね。
やっぱり英語はいろんな方が喋れますし、基本的には英語で外国人の方と会話する機会も多いと思うんですけども、
ですのでより高精度、精度高い指示を与えたい、また複雑な指示をAIに与える場合には、
システムメッセージを英語で設定するのが現時点では非常に有効かなと思いますので、こちらも補足にはなりますが、押さえていただけたらなというふうに思います。